JOY: Oh, my goodness!
You are crazy!
(horse neighs)
ZACK: Argh!
NARRATOR: Next on
Secrets of the Zoo...
SUZI: Oooh! Oooh!
NARRATOR: Doctors rush
to save a cheetah...
SUZI: Ready?
PRIYA: Easy, my love.
SUZI: You're my baby boy.
NARRATOR: Rescued macaws get
a new life at the zoo.
(bird moaning)
DAVID: There she is.
SUZI: There's your
new bird, David.
DAVID: Yeah.
CARRIE: Ooooh!
DEVON: Good job! Yay!
NARRATOR: And polar bear cubs
go off the deep end.
10,000 animals.
Two locations.
150 caregivers.
(roar)
This is Secrets of the Zoo.
EMILY: Here she comes!
Incoming! Woo!
So we have two of our
three baby cheetahs
here in the watering hole.
These girls are four months old.
We get them out here
as often as possible
just to get those muscles
ready to run.
So we have our yellow Labs,
we raise our Labs
with the cheetahs.
They're kind of like
a security blanket, I would say.
It's a sibling that
has more confidence.
So if one of our cats is
just a little bit nervous,
the dog kind of walks first
and that cat will follow him.
And they love running
maybe a little bit more
than the cheetahs do.
(dog barking)
SUZI: Perfect.
That's perfect. That's perfect.
Are you a good boy?
PRIYA: Are you ready
to bring him?
SUZI: It's alright, buddy.
PRIYA: We have two minutes.
Yes, two and a half minutes
to leave.
SUZI: Come on, Emmett.
We need to go.
You're stalling.
He knows.
Come on, come on!
NARRATOR: Emmett,
a nine-month-old cheetah
is a fighter, overcoming
the odds since a baby,
hand-raised by the zoo staff.
SUZI: Emmett was a very
compromised cat when we got him.
He was about two weeks old,
he was full of pneumonia,
Bordetella, feline herpes;
he was just about dead.
None of the other cats
survived in the litter.
Here's your buddies!
Oh, they're all here!
(laughs)
You guys, wish him luck.
But unfortunately,
as he grew bigger,
we noticed his shoulder
never fully developed.
NARRATOR: Emmett's joint is
missing bone and cartilage.
Untreated, Emmett's shoulder
may restrict him
to a painful life
without running.
SUZI: Are you going with him?
Are you going to be
his little buddy?
You are his rock.
You're not going.
You have to stay, I know.
So we're on our way
to Ohio State,
and he will have surgery.
PRIYA: Alright, let's go!
SUZI: I have had
two cheetahs here
that I put my heart and soul in,
and he's one of them.
It's nerve-racking.
I mean, he's got a big part
of my heart.
(sighs) Valium for me.
PRIYA: I have six bottles.
So you're in good shape.
SUZI: Thank you.
(music)
(squawking)
JOY: Hi, Kitty!
How are you, darling?
So that's my daughter.
(squawking)
And you can hear her calling me.
What are you doing?
Hi!
Yeah, I know.
I'm gonna come see you.
I have a flamingo daughter
named Haleakala.
And she likes to greet me
every time I go into
the flamingo yard.
Haleakala!
Where's that bird?
Where's that girl?
Come here, little lady!
I want a hug.
She in particular will yell
at me and then charge on over.
Oh, my goodness! You're crazy.
And she runs right into me
and then does a happy dance.
Are you happy I came to see you?
Yay!
(squawking)
She pulls at my heartstrings.
So that's not a relationship
that happens every day,
and we really cherish the ones
that we do have like that.
Our relationship started back
when she was in the egg.
We help raise our flamingos,
and they hear our voice
in the egg as they're hatching,
and sometimes the flamingos will
imprint on particular people.
You never stop talking.
(squawking)
You never stop talking, do you?
And this one in particular has
a personality or flamingo-ality
that is very rambunctious.
(squawking) Thank you, buddy.
There's a flamingo hairstyle.
They might be hairdressers if
they had professions as humans.
It's not always
the best hairstyle
that you get at the end,
but they seem to enjoy it.
Oof, ha ha, alright,
let me see your feet.
Several of them
do have leg tapings.
And this is because
their growth plates
when they're growing
are sometimes not even.
In the wild, they would be less
likely to survive a long life.
Check those wings.
NARRATOR: Haleakala will be
heading to the pool
to begin hydrotherapy sessions,
so her leg condition
doesn't worsen.
JOY: We're working with them
getting them up and moving,
and one of the best ways
is hydrotherapy,
or just moving around in water
and kind of stimulate the body
to correct itself.
NARRATOR:
Joy will prep the pool
for Haleakala's hydrotherapy
later today.
JOY: I got to go.
You got to be a bird, okay?
I'm going to see you later.
Love you!
Okay, stay, stay, okay.
(squawking)
I got to go. I got to go.
I'm sorry!
NARRATOR: 16 macaws rescued
from a hoarding situation
in Alabama will soon arrive
at the Columbus Zoo.
WOUTER: Oh, my goodness.
HEATHER: Oh! There they are!
EMILY: The exotic pet market
is not great.
Macaws can go for
thousands of dollars,
and so this guy was probably
breeding them to sell.
They were living in caging
with no doors,
with moldy water filters.
They were getting
wet dog food to eat.
It's just a horrible situation,
you know, you hate
to hear about that,
but hopefully their story has a
happy ending with us at the zoo.
NARRATOR: The macaws are lucky
to be alive.
Now the team will determine
if they're well enough
to survive the drive
back to Ohio.
EMILY: Birdies!
WOUTER: Look at them!
HEATHER: Hi!
EMILY: You're cute.
HEATHER: They look
so much better
than I thought they
were going to look.
EMILY: Oh, yeah,
they look great.
You're coming home!
Are you coming to the zoo?
(chirps)
Yes!
HEATHER: You already
trained him.
EMILY: Yes.
HEATHER: We weren't expecting
these birds to be socialized
to humans really at all,
so seeing that bird
being comfortable around us,
and one of the scarlet macaws
was really responding to music
and dancing, it was
a really special moment.
EMILY: What are you doing?
Oh!
Oh, my.
You're cute.
You guys like Adele.
I understand. I like Adele, too.
First glance at
all of these birds,
they don't look too terrible,
but it's hard to tell without
doing a proper vet exam.
Hi.
NARRATOR: Macaws, like many
other exotic animals,
mask their illness
as a way to survive.
Any bird showing outward signs
of weakness
is likely very sick.
TERRY: You can see his wing
does not extend on this side
like it does on the other side.
WOUTER: Once we get to the zoo,
we'll get an x-ray of that.
It's probably an old break.
JOHN: Old break, yeah,
that's what we thought.
HEATHER: This guy's beak
almost looks like
his nare was ripped down.
And it doesn't really
look like a prolapse,
because his cloaca is closed up,
um, like it should be,
but it's bulging behind it,
so it could be lots of
scar tissue that built up.
TERRY: And I suspect maybe
it was from an egg binding
or something like that,
the vet said it's very rare.
WOUTER: So he'd be
one of the ones
I would keep an eye on
during transport,
just because he's breathing
a little heavier,
he's got that squinty eye.
Look at the other one,
he's got his eye wide open,
ready to come over and say hi.
EMILY: We keep an eye on you.
WOUTER: Yeah.
EMILY: We don't really know
if they're sick
or their health conditions
until we get a full checkup
by our vet staff.
Right now, we need to treat
each of these birds
as if their life is on the line.
They could have
major health issues,
and they could be
in big trouble.
PRIYA: Easy, my love.
WHITNEY: Ready?
PRIYA: Yeah, I got the front.
SUZI: I got the end.
SUZI: Are we out?
WHITNEY: Lower.
PRIYA: He's out.
PRIYA: So we've just arrived
at Ohio State University,
and we're about to do
Emmett's surgery
for his joint replacement.
SUZI: It's alright, buddy.
You're alright.
PRIYA: We're just getting ready
to induce his anesthesia,
so we'll go ahead
and inject him,
get him down, stabilize him.
SUZI: You tell me
when you're ready.
PRIYA: Um, we are ready.
SUZI: Hey, buddy.
PRIYA: Emmett has a condition
in which his cartilage
did not develop appropriately
in a section of the bone.
So he doesn't have
a normal joint,
which is obviously very damaging
to a bone that's
constantly in motion.
SUZI: You want him out?
PRIYA: Mm-hmm.
SUZI: You want to come out here?
He's a shooter, remember.
PRIYA: Yeah. Oh, I know.
SUZI: Hey, buddy. Hey.
I don't want to be
right in front of him.
PRIYA: Yeah, no,
don't be in front of him.
We are aiming to try and
regenerate that area of the bone
to try and fill it,
cover it in cartilage
and hope that he develops
a normal joint.
SUZI: Okay. Yep.
PRIYA: Ready?
SUZI: Emmett. Yep.
We got it. We got it.
PRIYA: Easy, love. Easy, love.
Easy, love.
SUZI: It's okay. It's okay.
I am very nervous.
You know, it's like watching
your child in pain.
It's very nerve-racking for me.
SUZI: You're alright. Good boy.
BRANNON: Here, bub.
You want to come lay?
SUZI: Good boy.
NARRATOR: Emmett's
shoulder surgery
is common in
domestic dogs and cats,
but this is the first time
a cheetah is undergoing
this procedure.
PRIYA: There's a lot
riding on today.
It's never been done before,
so there's an element
of unknown.
And cheetahs are
incredibly unique
with their anatomy
and physiology
and immunology is
so, so different.
We can't predict
what's going to happen,
but we really want it to work.
JONATHAN: Yeah, no,
that will work.
PRIYA: Okay.
JONATHAN: I just don't want to
put him in a stress position
for his shoulders.
SUZI: We have fortunately one
of the best orthopedic surgeons
in the world.
Dr. Jonathan Dyce, he's
a miracle man, in my opinion.
If Jonathan takes on the case,
he has confidence he can fix it.
JONATHAN: Okay, are we good?
Looks like it.
ELIZABETH: Yeah. Looks like it.
JONATHAN: Good.
PRIYA: My concern is
that I'm not entirely sure
we know exactly what's going on
until we're in there.
JONATHAN: I'm going
to make an incision,
I need you to try and help come
through the fascia there.
PRIYA: If this procedure
isn't successful,
he may not have
to have it amputated,
that would be worst, worst,
worst-case scenario.
But it certainly may
become a joint
that may end up getting
a little bit fused,
and he may lose some function
in that limb.
I think we're all a little,
a little anxious about it.
(sighs)
SUZI: Waiting.
JONATHAN: You got to hold
that for me.
PRIYA: Cheetah Emmett right now
is in the operating room,
and having a look at that joint
and getting ready
to start fixing it.
Obviously we're all
rooting for him,
he's an animal that has
a special place in our heart
from rescuing him as a cub
and treating him
for all of his problems
when he was a little baby.
So, fingers crossed,
we really want this to go well.
JONATHAN: Hey, Priya,
this is interesting.
If you want to lean in here.
Fantastic.
What I was expecting
to find in here
was that all of this tissue
would be loose and fragmented,
and what he's actually done
is a very good job
of spontaneous repair.
All of the cartilage
is also quite solid.
Now this is actually remodeled
very well, spontaneously.
PRIYA: Oh, good. Wonderful.
Oh, Emmett.
It was absolutely amazing,
there was no way we could tell
without going in,
but he's healing himself.
Cheetahs being cheetahs,
always quirks and always
a little bit weird.
He actually started to heal
and self-resolve himself,
which has never been seen before
and would not be expected
in a dog or a cat.
JONATHAN: The news is good.
He's actually healing
remarkably well.
SUZI: Really?
I'm so happy!
PRIYA: It took
everyone by surprise
that we didn't have to go
to major surgery
to fix this problem.
But Emmett's really not
out of the woods yet.
We really haven't seen this
kind of regrowth before,
so we don't know what to expect.
The next steps for Emmett
involve getting him some R&R,
slowly reintroducing him
to exercise,
but the real test is going to be
if we can get Emmett
up to running speed
and out into the yard and doing
what our normal cheetahs do.
SUZI: Can you come here, buddy?
Can you just lay down
for a little bit?
Hey. Hey.
(purring)
I know, you're a good boy.
You're a good boy.
(kiss) I know.
Want to lay down? Come on.
Let's lay down.
Just because he has
a clean bill of health,
there aren't 100% guarantees.
So, everything's pointing
to it will be good,
but we're just going to
have to wait and see.
(dog barking)
He loves laps.
He's my lap cheetah.
PRIYA: You big baby.
NARRATOR: Emmett will recover
and regain strength
before attempting to run
once again at full speed.
SUZI: You did very good.
Yes, you did.
You're my boy.
You're my baby boy.
(purring)
(music)
DEVON: There she goes!
You guys, show them
how it's done!
ELIZABETH: There!
What is mom doing?
DEVON: What do you think?
NARRATOR: It's sink or swim
for twin baby polar bear cubs,
testing the water
for the first time.
CARRIE: Today we are working on
giving our cubs pool time,
swimming lessons;
they're still learning.
We have been so invested
in Nuniq and Neva
since the moment they were born.
We're so excited
to see them grow,
but also to see their mom,
Aurora, take care of them.
ASHLEY: They are both so weirded
out by her being in the pool.
DEVON: Yeah.
ASHLEY: Like they're hiding.
DEVON: I know.
NARRATOR: Neva and Nuniq are
getting swimming lessons
from mama polar bear Aurora.
Once they prove their
swimming skills here,
they'll take on the deep end
inside the polar bear habitat.
DEVON: They are getting
more comfortable now.
ASHLEY: Yeah.
DEVON: They're like, alright,
mom's out of the pool.
CARRIE: I just want to see them
go like 'rawr' and jump on it.
ASHLEY: Come on. You can do it!
DEVON: Oh, there we go!
Good job.
NARRATOR:
Once in the deep pool,
if the bear cubs
get in over their heads
with mom by their side,
it will be impossible for
the keepers to intervene.
ASHLEY: They're very cautious
with the water
since they aren't real
comfortable swimmers,
so they're still testing it out.
CARRIE: These baby steps are
so vitally important to the cubs
for their safety,
for the mom's safety.
We just don't want to put
anyone in a situation
where they might get hurt.
We're not in what we call
free contact;
there's always a barrier
between us and the bears.
And even with the cubs,
that's the same.
We have three polar bear cubs
currently, two different moms.
One has twins,
one has a single cub.
And these are actually
the only three polar bear cubs
born this year in zoos
in North America.
(laughs)
DEVON: She's like, wait,
that was kind of fun,
I might do it again.
CARRIE: It's okay.
You're a dirty, dirty bear.
NARRATOR: Finally,
the twin polar bear cubs
inch their way
up to the water's edge.
CARRIE: This one's
gonna swim first.
ASHLEY: Yeah, swim out there
and get it.
Good job! Yay!
DEVON: Awesome.
CARRIE: Good job!
ASHLEY: Yay!
CARRIE: Good job! You did it!
Did you just see that,
that she...
She just did that, right?
NARRATOR: Neva and Nuniq will
continue swimming lessons
before facing the deep pool
in the polar bear habitat.
CARRIE: Today's a good day.
JOY: Who's going swimming today?
Is Miss Haleakala
going swimming?
Doo! Hi!
(squawking)
Someone's happy. Are you happy?
Haleakala and Martini,
who has some arthritis,
he had surgery
when he was younger,
we're going to do
some swimming with them
to allow them to do some
nice physical therapy.
And it helps out their joints.
We're going to head back
and lead them over
to the manatee building.
Come on, buddy boy!
Pink dinosaurs crossing through.
Just hold on a moment.
Come on.
We kind of like to joke that
they're pink Velociraptors.
But birds are living dinosaurs.
They have hydrotherapy buddies,
so Martini or one
of the other adult birds
might be a little bit
more at ease
if they have a buddy
to go with them.
Yeah. (squawking)
He never shuts up.
MALLORY: I know,
Tini hasn't made a peep!
JOY: Let's go, buddy,
here we go. Inside.
NARRATOR: Today's session
includes a new element
guaranteed to get
the flamingos moving--
stingrays!
MALLORY: We ready
to go to the pool?
JOY: Ready? Are you ready?
Are you ready? Are you ready?
The large amount of stingrays
in this pool
are up here on vacation.
Their habitat is getting
renovated currently.
And so that's just kind of
excellent enrichment
for the flamingos.
They're going to be extra aware
of their environment
and the new things that are
moving underneath their feet.
Hopefully it will get them
moving a little bit more,
which is great.
Are you ready to meet stingrays?
(squawking)
And then also the stingrays
are getting enriched,
because I don't think
they've ever seen
a flamingo before either.
You're gonna swim
with the stingrays!
I think she sees them,
she sees them.
(squawking)
I think the stingrays are going
to probably be circling around
just kind of investigating.
But I don't think that they're
going to be getting too brave
with the flamingos.
We trim their barbs
so they don't have a response
that would trigger anything,
and we keep an eye on everybody
to make sure that
they're all comfortable.
Let me grab Haleakala.
Oh! There we are!
(squawking)
What you think? What you think?
I think she is back happy
in the pool again.
Once we get the flamingos
in the water,
they immediately get
their feet moving.
Stingray!
Did you see the stingrays?
Look, they're
underneath you now.
They get a little bit
more alert,
which is actually pretty good,
because then it will encourage
them to swim a little bit more.
Do you see stingrays?
They're underneath!
Look underneath.
(music)
So she's just learned that she
can stick her head underwater
and check out underneath.
When you see flamingos, they're
iconic for standing on one leg,
which is actually
an energy-saving mechanism
for them,
so hydrotherapy is
very important,
because to actually get them
to do exercise,
they don't normally
do that very often.
Encouraging them
to move around a lot
is basically
therapeutic for them
and getting them to use their
muscles in an encouraging way.
MALLORY: Hydrotherapy! Woo!
JOY: Woo-hoo!
MALLORY: I think that was a very
successful hydrotherapy session.
JOY: It's another
'I love my job' day.
We have a lot of those.
Don't we? Don't we?
Yes, we do. Boop!
ZACK: Morning, guys.
Morning, Goby.
Feeling alright today, big man?
NARRATOR: 90 miles away
at the zoo's conservation park,
the animals are about to get
their daily check-in from Zack.
ZACK: Hey, Tuffy.
Hey, over here.
My main responsibilities
here at The Wilds
is to take care
of our pasture area.
We just try to make sure
everybody's where
they're supposed to be.
We'll check any
of our medical cases.
Also, we have a couple animals
that could be expecting births,
and we'll try to
check on those animals
and make sure we don't have
any surprises in the morning.
Good morning.
How's it going, Flicka?
What are you doing
out here by yourself?
You feeling alright, girl?
NARRATOR: Flicka, a female
Przewalski horse,
is all alone,
separated from the herd,
which is cause for concern.
ZACK: Anytime for me, I see
this, this is a key indicator.
I need to make sure
this animal is okay.
Check for lameness,
check for any wounds on her,
demeanor changes.
Seeing her away
from the group like that
is definitely a red flag.
These are those small cues that
if you can nip it in the bud
really quick, you can really
save a really bad situation.
These guys are
extremely rare animals.
These horses are one of the most
primitive horse species
you can find.
This animal almost
went extinct in the wild,
and so just the loss of one
would be a horrible thing
for us.
ZACK: Good morning.
How's it going, Flicka?
What are you doing
out here by yourself?
You feeling alright, girl?
NARRATOR: Flicka,
a female Przewalski horse
is all by herself.
The herd is nowhere in sight.
(neigh)
ZACK: You can see she's neighing
for the rest of the group.
Horses, come on!
Here they come.
Come on, girls.
(whinny)
Within the herd,
there's a pecking order.
They usually have
a couple animals on top
that are dominant, and then you
got a couple on the lower end
that are just
kind of subordinates.
Flicka, she's kind of
the outsider.
A lot of times
she's away from the group,
but she was off by herself
a little more than usual
and a little bit
further distances.
So we're going to have the vets
take a quick look at her
and just make sure
everything looks OK.
NARRATOR: Flicka will come in
for a full examination
later today.
(birds chirping)
In Alabama, macaws saved
from a hoarding situation
are about to begin their
long journey back to Ohio,
where the zoo doctors are
waiting to examine the birds
and give them a new life.
WOUTER: Emily, if you don't mind
coming in here with me,
just in case
I get feet or a beak.
EMILY: Mm-hmm, yep.
Macaw beaks are
very intimidating.
We're just going to have
to be really careful
when we're maneuvering
them around,
because we could get bit.
It could get hairy.
WOUTER: Hey, bubba.
(squawk)
Come here. (squawk)
Oh, buddy, I know.
EMILY: They don't know that
we're here to help them.
That's the tricky part,
is like you want to be able
to tell them, like,
'Just get in the crate.
It'll be fine.
We're going to take you
to Columbus.'
But, unfortunately, we can't
really communicate with them,
so we're just going to move
as quick as possible.
That's the best thing
we can do for them,
and hopefully build that trust
so they can realize
we're the good guys.
(squawking)
WOUTER: Woo!
He's chunky.
EMILY: You're like a ninja.
HEATHER: That was so nice!
WOUTER: I feel like
a waiter right now.
Um, could I take your order,
please?
EMILY: May I have two hyacinths?
WOUTER: Two hyacinths?
EMILY: Yes, please.
WOUTER: OK. What do you want?
Males or females?
EMILY: I want all of them.
WOUTER: Hi, bubba,
I'm so sorry for all this.
You're really worried
about their beak.
They hold on and
then they grind.
So always get the head first.
As soon as you can get the head,
you've got to be careful,
you don't want the head
to be loose
while the body is
swinging around,
so it's kind of a double grab.
There you go.
Inside.
Nice job.
EMILY: Waah!
(phone ringing)
SUZI: Hello.
WOUTER: Hello, how are you?
SUZI: Good.
WOUTER: We just loaded them up.
One of them has a leg
that is swollen and hot.
And there's one that
just doesn't look like
it's breathing just 100%,
we might want to get
the vets to look at
sooner better than later,
so maybe tomorrow.
SUZI: As soon, you know,
shortly when they get in here
and then they plan on doing
full work-ups on them,
because we don't know anything.
WOUTER: Good.
SUZI: Good job, good job.
WOUTER: Hey, we're not
there yet, halfway there.
NARRATOR: The macaws are
on their way to Columbus
where the zoo team anxiously
awaits their arrival.
EMILY: Bye-bye.
BIRD: Bye-bye.
WOUTER: We're on our way to
Columbus, get out of our way.
HEATHER: Now just
12 short hours.
ZACK: Today we're going
to bring in
our Przewalski wild horse
female herd.
I noticed that Flicka
was off by herself
a little more than usual.
Maybe something
might be off with her.
So we're gonna have the vets
take a quick look at her
and just make sure
everything looks OK.
Since we're gonna go ahead
and bring her in,
we're gonna bring
the whole herd in.
Anytime you have an animal
within a herd,
you don't want to remove it
from that herd,
it's gonna put things
in disarray,
everybody's going to be
high stress levels
and really worried.
So by keeping the herd together
as we take her in,
is the best thing for it.
CASEY: Here she comes.
ZACK: Who's getting the blood?
KRYSTIN: I'm going to try.
ZACK: Krystin, woo!
PATRICK: Nice, Squeaks.
ZACK: The vampire!
PATRICK: Nice.
KRYSTIN: You guys have all
jinxed me now.
(laughs)
ZACK: You've got to work
under pressure.
CURT: We are trying to
get blood off Flicka.
She's been acting just
a little bit different.
Due to her age,
she's born around 2000, 2001.
We just want to get some blood
and see how everything
is going on.
PATRICK: Look at that,
freakin' nailed it.
ELLEN: We'll take a look
and see if we can
see anything more.
Yeah, nothing obvious.
CURT: Check her eyes, too.
ELLEN: Check her eyes?
CURT: Yeah, she kind of had
a hard time finding the holes
back there
that she usually does.
ELLEN: OK, can I get around you?
Is that alright or is that...
No, OK, I'll work from here.
ZACK: Yeah, try, I just don't
want you to get bit.
Argh!
Alright,
alright, alright.
(clattering)
(neighs)
ZACK: We're bringing in Flicka
and get her checked out.
That has become our priority.
NARRATOR: Flicka is
a 16-year-old mare
that's not too happy
about having a checkup.
ZACK: Yeah, try, I just don't
want you to get bit.
Argh!
Alright, alright, alright.
(neighs)
ELLEN: She's not
very relaxed, obviously.
ZACK: Yeah, try, I just don't
want you to get bit.
ELLEN: No, I don't want
to get bit either.
Relax, my friend, relax.
Oh, I think we may have
a cataract forming.
This animal has a cataract
forming in its left eye.
Eye issues are really
painful sometimes,
and when animals
are uncomfortable,
they often will separate
themselves from the herd.
So I think it's definitely
one of the possibilities
as to why she's keeping
herself apart.
That eye looks better
than that eye.
A lot of change, though.
DAN: OK, are we done with her?
ELLEN: We're done.
NARRATOR: Luckily, Flicka's eye
does not require
immediate attention.
If it gets worse, the staff
will bring her in ASAP.
If her blood test
comes back OK,
herd politics may be
Flicka's last hurdle.
ZACK: Now that we've brought
the whole herd in,
this may be a chance for things
to mix up a little bit
within the herd,
so Flicka will have
the opportunity
to reestablish herself.
It will take a couple days,
and we'll be able to see
where Flicka ends up,
if she goes back to
the same behavior she's had
for the last couple days or so,
or if she gets back
to normal again.
(music)
SUZI: I'm really excited
for you to see him.
PRIYA: Good!
SUZI: Emmett had a big, gaping
hole in his shoulder,
so we didn't know if he would
ever be able to run.
So Priya's gonna come over
and check him.
And we're really hopeful
that we get to start
running Emmett again.
PRIYA: He looks great.
SUZI: Doesn't he look good?
PRIYA: Yeah!
PRIYA: Will he let me
have a feel and just see?
SUZI: I think he will.
PRIYA: OK.
SUZI: Can Priya check your leg?
Can she check your leg?
Good boy.
PRIYA: Hi, bud. Hi, handsome.
SUZI: What do you think?
PRIYA: Hi, bud.
SUZI: What do you think? Oh.
Well...
(laughs)
PRIYA: It feels great.
It feels very solid.
There's no swelling in there,
there's no fluid in there.
SUZI: Think we can run him?
PRIYA: Yeah?
It gives me anxiety,
but yeah, I think he's ready.
The run will be the moment
of truth, so...
SUZI: Let's do it.
PRIYA: Let's see how he does.
SUZI: Now it's time
for us to see
if Emmett can do
the cheetah run.
Ew, it's awfully wet.
WHITNEY: Yeah, that doesn't
look good.
SUZI: Look at this.
Yeah, I'm not liking what I see.
Two days of rain
doesn't help us.
I don't want to take
any chances with him,
after all he's been through.
Well, let's not do it,
let's see if we can get them
to bring him out.
Let's just let him play.
WHITNEY: Alright, Emily,
we're ready for Emmett,
you can bring him down.
EMILY: Copy, on the way.
SUZI: Here he comes.
Oh! (laughs)
Hey, buddy.
What do you think?
I think he's a little nervous.
I think it might be good
to get Cullen down here.
EMILY: Make him feel
more comfortable?
SUZI: Yeah.
We still noticed Emmett
might be a little skittish,
so we're gonna bring
Cullen down,
that's his dog that
he believes is his brother,
and that's gonna give him
the confidence
he didn't have before
he walked in here.
EMILY: Here he is.
SUZI: Nervous.
EMILY: Come here, Cullen.
Where is he?
SUZI: There they go. (laughs)
There's the confidence.
(laughs)
Look at these two.
He was obviously
more comfortable
when Cullen got down.
Let's go ahead and
send Cash and Coby.
We have two other dogs
that are cheetah dogs.
Emmett got to be friends
with all of them.
Ooh, here he goes.
Look at him jump.
I'm not sure if those three
think they're a cheetah,
or Emmett thinks
he's a yellow Lab.
Look at him. Ooh! Oh!
(laughs)
Don't hurt that shoulder, buddy.
Oh!
EMILY: Well, I think
we made a good choice
in calling
the cheetah run today.
SUZI: Yeah.
Did you see him slide?
Emmett did beautifully today.
He got out here,
he explored the area.
He didn't limp
at the end of the day.
The next step is the run, and I
can't wait to see that guy run.
(music)
CARRIE: Carrie to Ellie.
ELLIE: Go ahead.
CARRIE: We're ready for bears.
ELLIE: I copy.
I'm going to be shifting
Aurora, Nuniq, and Neva
out into the main yard.
NARRATOR: It's time for
Aurora's twin polar bear cubs
to take their first plunge
into the habitat pool,
while all of
the zoo-goers watch.
CARRIE: Getting to this point
has been actually
years in the making.
We spent so much time
making sure
that they're strong
enough to swim,
that they wouldn't
have any fear.
When they are out here
standing on that big rock,
I can't help but be a little
nervous, a little anxious,
just hoping that everything
is gonna go OK.
(cheering)
(music)
Seeing these bears
do those same behaviors
that their cousins
in the wild also have.
They learned to pounce
on the ice,
and they learned to dive
in the water,
and so this is exactly
what we want for them.
They did amazing.
We've seen them since they were
these little bitty things.
I mean, they were the size
of a stick of butter,
about a pound,
they would fit in the palm of
your hand when they were born.
Now they're bears, you know,
like, we've seen them
and we've cared for them
and we've loved them,
but now they're out there
being bears.
It's been a really fun week
for all of us here at the zoo.
(music)
NARRATOR: 16 rescued macaws
arrive at the Columbus Zoo.
If their medical exam
checks out,
they will be given new homes.
SUZI: Office pets? For everyone?
RANDY: Not me.
WOUTER: You're like Oprah.
Everybody gets humpback whales!
(laughs)
RANDY: Everybody
gets a macaw.
WOUTER: And a cheetah.
SUZI: Macaws for everybody.
WOUTER: Yeah.
Be careful.
That's all you.
RANDY: Not knowing
its history,
we're gonna run a whole panel
where you swab the eyes,
the mouth, and the rectum,
and then we'll send it in for
tests for infectious diseases.
We're going to assume nothing
and do a complete examination.
WOUTER: Doesn't close it much.
DAVID: This one feels
a little stiff.
RANDY: Yeah.
DAVID: It's pretty fused.
NARRATOR: Three macaws appear
to have medical issues
and are weak.
The doctors must investigate
right away.
WOUTER: This guy definitely
is not doing great.
(squawk) Oh, shh, shh, shh.
DAVID: The issues that we were
kind of worried about:
slightly droopy wings,
not acting totally right.
RANDY: With birds,
they are very adept
at hiding clinical signs,
so when a bird looks a little
off, it's probably pretty ill.
It could, in fact, be
a life-threatening situation
with a severe infection.
RANDY: Everybody, you guys
step back a little bit.
SUZI: During those procedures,
we noticed one of the macaws
had an egg.
She should have laid it by now,
so she hasn't,
so we're very concerned.
How long would she normally
hold the egg?
RANDY: It should be laid
in five days.
SUZI: Could that be an egg
that's been there for months?
RANDY: Could be, yeah.
DAVID: Yeah.
SUZI: When a bird
hasn't laid an egg,
it can cause all sorts
of problems.
We don't know how long
this egg has been there.
We're hoping that we can
extract the egg,
but we're not sure what
we're going to get into
when we get in there.
If we don't take care of it,
it can eventually kill her.
RANDY: It's pretty clear that
it's not going anywhere
without some assistance.
(groans)
SUZI: Can you get it out whole?
RANDY: That's our intention,
that's our goal.
So let's, uh, let's go get it.
SUZI: Now do you have
to surgically do this?
RANDY: We're hoping not.
SUZI: OK.
RANDY: That's the last option.
SUZI: Whenever I'm
in the operating room,
I'm always a nervous wreck,
especially one of my animals
that I'm responsible for.
But I really feel bad
for this bird,
because she's had
such a rough life.
It just hurts me.
DAVID: Feel anything?
RANDY: Yeah, I can feel the egg.
DAVID: Good.
SUZI: So how, are you
suctioning it out or...?
RANDY: Just massage it.
SUZI: And it's moving,
you can feel it?
RANDY: It's not,
it hasn't yet.
The idea is to lube up the egg
as well as we can
and to gently massage it
down the tract.
But I can't get the egg to move,
it's lodged tightly
in the reproductive wall.
DAVID: So this situation
can be very dangerous,
just 'cause if
that egg ruptures,
all of that yolk and everything
can actually go into her abdomen
and cause some wicked infection
and generally death.
SUZI: Not moving?
RANDY: It's broken.
The eggshell is fractured
and collapsed,
so now we're just suctioning out
the contents.
We were unable to
get it out intact.
NARRATOR:
With the egg in pieces,
this just became an emergency.
SUZI: Not moving?
RANDY: It's broken.
NARRATOR: A macaw's condition
becomes serious
when an egg inside her breaks.
DAVID: The egg is
fractured in there,
so we're gonna help gently
flush out her uterine area,
and then we're gonna suck out
all the contents of the egg,
so it doesn't travel the
opposite way into her abdomen,
and then we need to try
to tease that eggshell out.
RANDY: So you can see
the back half of the eggshell
has collapsed.
SUZI: OK, yeah.
RANDY: And now we've suctioned
all the content out.
SUZI: Could she pass that?
RANDY: Yeah, oh, yeah,
I think she'll pass that.
SUZI: OK, good.
DAVID: The egg cracked
pretty quickly,
and that indicates to me
that the egg's probably not
a healthy egg to begin with,
and this could be due
to it being in there
for a longer period of time.
Knowing what this bird
has gone through
and knowing the trauma
and neglect
that it's probably experienced,
if we can help her be
as healthy as she can be,
that's a win in my book.
SUZI: Is she coming out?
SHAWN: She's blinking.
RANDY: Awful?
WOMAN: 'My cloaca hurts.'
SUZI: Yeah, she's gonna
bite you in about...
RANDY: What? After all
I've done for her?
(laughs)
Hi.
DAVID: We're about to hear
some screaming very shortly.
(bird moans)
There she is.
SUZI: Don't kid yourself.
DAVID: OK, baby.
She's back, her brain's back on,
she's recovered well
from anesthesia,
and she hates me just as much.
SUZI: I am protective
of these birds,
because they've been
down a crappy path,
and I feel responsible
to get them out of that path
and to get them
in a perfect situation.
There's your new bird, David.
DAVID: Yeah, I'm sure
she loves me.
SUZI: Yeah.
(bird moans)
DAVID: Baby, it's OK.
(moaning)
(laughs)
PRIYA: Was that you or her?
It sounds like The Exorcist.
(moaning)
DAVID: Shh, shh, shh.
NARRATOR: Out at
the Conservation Park,
Flicka the horse is hopefully
working her way back
into the herd.
ZACK: Alright, so this morning
my big goal
is to try to find Flicka.
We brought her in
to see if there was
anything wrong with her.
She was acting a little bit off,
was staying away from the group,
and we had our veterinarians
run some blood work
and do a full analysis on them
to see if there was
anything wrong with her.
And turns out her blood work
came back positive,
and there was no issues
at all with her.
Turned out Flicka had a little
bit of cataract on her eye,
which isn't a great concern,
I mean, with her age
and where she's at,
those are things that happen.
But our biggest concern
right now
is that she's gonna incorporate
herself back in with the group.
Come on, girls.
Come on, Petra, Barbie.
Good girls.
Good morning, Barbie.
Barbie's the leader
of the group.
She wants to kick me
if I get too close.
Flicka, you feeling
any better today?
So now that we realize that
the blood work came back great
and health is not of concern,
I want to see how they interact
with each other,
so I want to keep watching her
and making sure that
there's no reason
why she's wanting to stay away
from the group.
So you can see Flicka still
keeps to the outside,
stays back a little bit,
but for the most part
she's here with the group.
Flicka, you seem to be
acting a little better.
For the most part,
she looks sound.
Whole herd's looking
really great.
No ill effects of any sort,
so really happy
everything went so well
and that everybody's
looking good.
Flicka is back with the herd,
completely incorporated herself,
and back to normal.
It's a huge sense of relief
to know that she's OK
and that the herd's
doing better.
Working with
Przewalski wild horses
is something that is a blessing.
This is an animal that is
almost extinct in the wild.
Who knows, Flicka could
have a baby one day,
and that baby could end up
back in its native range.
So it's really exciting to be
able to work with an animal
and increase their
global populations here in Ohio.
SUZI: I think the yard looks
perfect, the weather is perfect.
And there's really no way we're
gonna know if Emmett's joint
is really healed
unless he can run.
SHAWN: Yeah, definitely.
Let's see how he does.
NARRATOR: Today, for the first
time since surgery,
Emmett's shoulder will
be put to the test.
SUZI: The exciting thing
about today
is as people that come
to see Emmett running,
this is his first time,
and they're going
to have no idea
what this animal
has been through,
what the challenges have been
to get him to this point,
the surgeries, the rehab,
everything it has taken to get
Emmett to be healthy enough
that he can actually
run after the lure
and be the cheetah that
we're so excited to see.
SHAWN: Guys, we're gonna
go ahead and give this a shot.
If you want to get Emmett ready,
lure's already set.
WOMAN ON RADIO: We copy,
Shawn, that sounds good.
SUZI: If Emmett can come
out of that chute
and he can run
and chase that lure
and not be limping or
stop in the middle of it,
then we're gonna know he's OK.
This is the moment of truth.
WOMAN ON RADIO:
Alright, releasing Emmett.
SHAWN: Alright, get ready.
SUZI: Here he goes. This is it.
SUZI: This is
the moment of truth.
If Emmett can come
out of that chute
and he can run and chase
that lure and end it
and not be limping or stop
in the middle of it,
then we're gonna know he's OK.
Good job, buddy.
Oh, my gosh!
SHAWN: Look at him cheat.
SUZI: Oh.
EMILY: Good boy!
SHAWN: Oh, oh, oh, oh!
EMILY: Come on!
SUZI: Come on, buddy!
SUZI: Look at him!
Oh-ho-ho!
Good job, buddy!
You did it!
Look at him, he's a runner.
It started off a little shaky,
but that's normal.
But his legs look good,
he has very straight legs.
Cheetahs have a flat tail
that acts as a rudder,
and you could see Emmett using
that tail to make that turn,
and then once he was
in the straightaway,
man, he nailed it,
he was full-blown,
you could see him just
shooting down the runway,
all four feet up in the air
at the same time,
and that's what we want to see.
That's one beautiful cat.
You did so good.
SHAWN: Listen to the purr,
there's the purr.
SUZI: You're proud of yourself.
We got Emmett back!
SHAWN: I know.
SUZI: I think he's going to be
one of our fastest runners.
SHAWN: Could be.
SUZI: We did this!
SHAWN: Nice job.
SUZI: Good job, Emmett.
EMILY: You ready to go? We're
gonna go to a new room today.
NARRATOR: After months
of extensive training,
the rescued macaws are ready to
explore new areas of the zoo.
SUZI: Today's an exciting day,
because our macaws
that we rescued
are finally coming
out of quarantine,
and it's been a long haul,
because we had a lot
of health issues,
and we were able to find homes
for 13 of the birds.
Three of them we kept back,
and that was on purpose,
because all three of those
still have medical issues.
I'm very excited
to bring them over here,
because I really don't know
how they're going to react.
It's going to be their
first time out of the hospital.
EMILY: What do you think
about this?
There we go!
SUZI: Look at her.
EMILY: You like it?
The female hyacinth came to us
not wanting anything
to do with people.
We worked really hard, and
now she is excited to see us,
she runs to the front
of her cage.
She's really opened up
and come a long, long way.
I didn't think she'd be able
to learn to step up
because of her balance,
but she did,
and she's just you know,
surprising us, so...
SUZI: She's doing great.
These birds were in not a good
situation for a long time.
And it took an army to get them
in the shape that
they're in now.
EMILY: OK, do you think you can
handle both of these birds?
SUZI: If you go get
the other one?
EMILY: Uh-huh.
SUZI: Yeah.
BRANNON: This is
strictly Grover's
'cause she gets certain pellets.
This is a lot!
SUZI: Stop. I won't feed it
all to them.
My daughter works
in the department,
and she gets really mad at me,
because they take training
so seriously, which they should.
EMILY: You guys,
you're gonna be OK.
Suzi, don't feed them
all the food.
SUZI: I'm not.
EMILY: Don't feed her
all the food, Suzi.
SUZI: I'm not spoiling her.
I don't sneak in
macadamia nuts every day.
Come on, it's fun to spoil
people and animals.
OK, I better stop.
They have no idea, do they?
(squawk)
EMILY: Hey, Nige.
SUZI: Plenty of food here!
EMILY: How you doing?
We brought your girlfriend.
We have the two scarlet pair,
Nigel and Adele.
Getting them out of the woods
and taking care of all
their medical issues,
it took a lot of time.
Every single day,
multiple times a day,
working with them,
gaining their trust.
SUZI: Hi, you guys.
You're out of quarantine.
EMILY: What do you think?
SUZI: It took a while,
this one was so scared and shy.
EMILY: Yeah.
I think they're ready
to go places.
SUZI: I think I would definitely
start using them,
I would take them out.
I think it's gonna be good for
them to get in new environments,
and they look great.
She just even looks happier,
you know?
EMILY: Mm-hmm.
Suzi Rapp, I see you.
I have great peripheral vision.
SUZI: I was just looking
for an almond.
EMILY: After this,
we're going to be fat birds.
SUZI: It's pretty pathetic
that I'm the boss,
and I'm the one
who gets in trouble.
BIRD: Hello.
(laughs)